hi guys it's silver it again and today
I'm going to show you how to make cut
some scenery and I've been thinking
about doing this tutorial for a very
long time and I figured there are
actually quite a lot of tutorials about
this on YouTube but I figured I would
just make it very quick tutorial
covering as much as I can but just a
basic so anyone can learn really fast
how to do this okay so first off you
want to install the ICD 3 plugin and the
ASE exporter you need the rct3 plugin to
get the dimensions right in Sketchup and
the exporter to export to the ICD 3
importer so yeah ok that sounds weird
but I'll explain that later on anyway I
always like to work on a quarter tile
placement because that means that that
the object is more flexible in game you
can place it on a quarter tile instead
of a full tile it's just people who use
custom scenery usually appreciate that
so in this case I'm just going to make a
simple footer so I'm going to start off
with a circle and I want it for anyone
make a custom scenery if you use
anything circle shapes like a sphere or
a cylinder and Sketch up use a polygon
and not a circle because a circle has
many Poly's and that's going to lag your
game quite a lot I usually use a circle
of either 16 or eight sites eight sites
saves you some polygons but it looks
less smooth oops so I'm gonna go for a
16 right now and I'm gonna make a small
simple footer so let's see you can also
just use the full tile to see what it
would look like on a full tile because
this would be the the yeah the size of
the photo on a full tile so I guess
that's pretty much a bit too big
actually so I'm just gonna go for 80
centimeters just gonna type 0.8 in there
oh yeah always make sure that your game
is on metric because even though this
this listen tighten this plugin uses the
Oct 3 dimensions it's a lot easier if
you use the metric system because roller
coaster code 3 uses the metric system no
matter what your settings are so this is
my Twitter right now and I figure
because this is a footer just but this
is just for photos I'm gonna extend it a
little bit so if you've got terraforming
for example you can still have that you
know going into the ground server it
actually looks like a photo
and I'm gonna extend this actually I'm
gonna make this a bit lower because it's
not really one meter off the ground
usually it's about 30 centimeters I'd
say yeah that looks pretty good an hour
to find the middle of this I'm just
going to do this and it's something in
the middle right here real quick and
just like that I'm going to extend that
a bit when it comes to importing
textures you need to import the textures
right and you can only use textures that
are in the power of two and JPEGs so for
example if you've got a texture that's
70 by 70 it's not in the power of two
you can't use it all so it needs to be
square so if it's like 64 times 128 you
can't use it because it's not a square
so I'm gonna go into my tech students
folder if I can find that and it's over
here and all of these textures are I
think yeah they are square and they are
JPEGs and I'm just going to use a simple
wall texture for the bottom right here
okay and just gonna import that like and
this depends on the detail of the
texture for example this is I think a
128 texture which is what I'd recommend
because it's a high it's a high detail
texture but not too high detail that'll
wake up your game and for example 16 by
16 texture that's a very low quality so
I would not recommend using that so I'm
just gonna place that over there and I'm
gonna ping all of the sides with that so
I'm just gonna go to in model and take
that texture and just paint it all
around the sides like that make sure
that you paint every texture I am every
side with this because that's that's
going to be quite handy importing and
stuff and knowing which side is which
texture because right now this is not
even that important but it's just a
guideline and then for the middle
section I'm I do want to have a read
colorable text to it so if you want to
get recolor ball textures then all you
have to do is open paint wait I'll show
it usually what I do is I open paint
come on man paint
okay yeah there it is so open up paint
gets your signs to be like 128 no 64 by
64 that's a better idea and just take
one pure color like either pure rats
pure green or pure blue because whenever
you use recolor ball textures you can
use up to three recolor royal textures
in one piece and the first recoverable
texture is going to be red the second
one is going to be blue and the third
one's going to be green and since this
one is one recoverable texture I'm just
gonna make this right it doesn't really
matter that much but that's basically
how you get your recolor what texture is
done but in any case I've already done
that so I can already open those
textures since they are in my texture
file here is my pure red fire and I'm
just gonna stick that onto this side
because I want this to be a recolor well
this is the part of the photo that
connects the support to the footer parts
so you want not to have the same color
as the supports and if you set this to a
recolor ball in the importer you can
make this recallable okay and once again
make sure that you get every side and
now it's a very important part of the
Sketchup thing because now the model was
pretty much done and all you need to do
is group the different textures for the
rct3 imported to recognize okay I need
to make that right and I need to make
that concrete so you can select every
side that's what some people teach but
you can also just go the easy way and
say select all with the same material
and right click again make group and
then for yourself you're just going to
call this red so you know which texture
you use because you're going to have to
select those in the ICD 3 importer again
okay and for this one as well we're just
going to say all with the same material
and make group and entity info and then
just fill in the name of the texture
that you use because you're going to
create a reference in the ICD 3 importer
later on for that okay now I'm just
going to save my model to make sure that
I like don't lose it and then I'm going
to that's this is all good
there's nothing else you need to do in
Sketchup and I'm going to export it to
My Documents doesn't really matter where
you export it okay good and now now you
need to open the ICD 3 importer and
create an ovl now what you do in here is
you create a file that the rct3 importer
can recognize as a custom object file
and that you can later on actually
import into a custom scene resets so
first of all we're going to have to
select our textures right so first I'm
going to select the red picture and the
red texture and this one is going to be
recoverable so I'm gonna say one color
and then I'm going to import the other
texture which is over here and that is
where is it it should be somewhere in
here oh wait I forgot I actually well I
used the wrong name well that's not
going to be too much of a problem I use
this one okay yeah and no colors are
going to be changed and then you're
going to open the ase file that you
created in sketchup so open that ase
file and then it's going to say all
kinds of things first of all you want to
click this F because you did create
Sketchup to create it always do this
because otherwise it's going to be in
your game upside down or sideways or
some kind of weird coordinate system you
don't want to have that you want to to
get in the game straight and just the
way you actually model it and then for
faces you can want to make them
double-sided just in case for example if
you have an object that has one face but
textures on both sides then one of the
sites is going to be invisible if you
don't do this so for example I once made
a support set and I forgot to do the
double sided thing and the supporter
would be invisible from some angle so
that's that's not something that you
want and then for this we're just going
to click a and it automatically does the
arrow DS that's the level of details and
oops I was almost going to save now
prefix you're just gonna insert your own
name over here and the name of the
object is footer and then we get we're
going to want to just do it in my
document I guess and then you can go
ahead and create the ovl so then that's
done and then you would want to start
actually
the importing that ovl into the scenery
manager but before you do that you need
to want at one thing a text string this
is going to be the name of either the
sets or the object in the game or an
icon texture and this is going to be the
icon that you see in the game for
example maybe steel jungle you see those
supports icons to know which support
you're actually using so in the text
manager you're just going to take
they're both the name of the set and the
name of the object so for example my set
I want my set to be called silver Utz
footage so I do this then copy it and
that's done and then I'm gonna call this
bnm footer copy that and that's done so
I can use it I can use the top one for
this set and the bottom one for the
object and if you want to add another
object say if a coma for two then you
can just add another text thing then for
the icon textures I'm just going to load
a random texture for the icon for
example I mean browse into my textures
folder let's see let's say I want to use
now let's say I want to use this
okay that's stupid text do it then all
you need to do it's just do auto that
one and then it just gives you a cons
and it it scroop them over now because
it divided one icon into four icons that
should not happen but in any case it
should work and then just create a good
icon but icons on that important it's
just if you want your setup user
friendly for example now this is just
going to be something simple this is
just for the folder of the thing in
Program Files this is not for the actual
thing but I'm still gonna do this now I
can actually add the scenery so for
example first of all you want to select
the ovl that you used so once again we
need to and look for the ovl open that
thing and location within the theme
doesn't matter you can just add misc
over there and for the icon we're just
going to use these things and the name
string of the group has to be silver ATS
footers and the name strip name string
of the scenery that is the object that's
going to be the B&M footer the scenery
type I usually do Wars because a wall
straight because if you do this it's
going to pop up in walls but if you use
for example
let's say a small object like a small
scenery it's going to pop up in objects
and you can also make it a tree a shrub
of flowers whatever and that determines
where it's going to pop up but I like my
custom scenery to pop up under walls so
I'm just going to take wall now over
here you have to make the position zero
zero zero the size 4 4 4 and the size in
squares 1 1 and if you did it like I did
on 1/4 tile in Sketchup you're going to
have to select water tile over here but
if you did it on a full tile in Sketchup
you're going to have to do a full tile
over here now you can make all of these
things zero there there are some we're
definitely like there's some weird
parameters like that there's a manual to
this but it's very complicated and you
don't actually need them if you're just
importing normal scenery so you can you
can forget about those things now that I
think is pretty much finished oh yeah
you need to select the theme type I'm
just gonna go for generic and I'm going
to save the theme file so I can add
things to it later on and just gonna
call it silver at photos again this is
just for you for yourself so you can see
what it was and then install it and then
then you're done that's it and you've
just installed your first custom scenery
piece let's open the game ok so right
now I am in the game and if all went
well man my my footage should be right
here and yes it is and you can see that
stupid icon because it's messed up and
it's it's a quarter piece of the icon
not sure what happened over there but
you can see that you can place the photo
it's looking ugly as it was in Sketchup
and it's not a quarter tile placement
but as you can see you can place it
either in the middle of a square or on
the sides or even on centers of like
some of the edges in any case this is
this is probably the best placement you
can have for a custom scenery piece and
you can also see that you can recolor it
in any way that you want and I can show
you that it's exactly the same color as
maybe steel jungle which is what you
want to have if you're doing fritters
and this is basically the standard
recolor ball color option so as you can
see it's exactly the same color so
that's all great so yeah thanks for
watching
hope you can make some cool awesome
custom scenery sets with this tutorial